hello welcome
- this Monday's a daily homeroom for
those of you all who are new here what
this is something we're trying to do to
keep us all connected as we have the
school closures going on throughout the
world many of y'all know Khan Academy
were not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and when we found
out that the school closures were
happening we realized that we had to do
many things that is a not-for-profit
with this mission we had to step up to
support you students parents and
teachers any way we could so we had
already over the last many years because
never seen this situation we had built
content there's Khan Academy kids which
is for the young crowd ages two to six
in reading writing social-emotional
learning and then on Khan Academy not
Khan Academy kids you can continue on in
math English and language arts the
sciences humanities SAT practice and we
realized that we should also do things
that can help structure your day so we
released some of those daily schedules
out a couple of weeks ago that I we've
heard good feedback from from from all
of y'all we've been doing parent
webinars teacher webinars and we are
doing this daily homeroom which is a
place to answer any questions you might
have so as you listen definitely and
whether it's on Facebook or YouTube type
in questions for myself or our guests
this is going to be Adam green from our
content team and we're going to try to
answer as many as we can over the course
of the next few minutes I do want to
give a special thanks to several
corporations who have stepped up in the
last couple weeks Khan Academy is
fundamental is funded with philanthropic
donations and we were running at a
deficit even before our traffic spiked
by two and a half 3x over the last
couple of weeks and Bank of America
followed by 18 t google.org and of
artists have really stepped up and
helped us close some of that gap but I
do want to emphasize any corporations
listening or any individuals listening
every dollar matters we are still
running at a deficit and we want the
resources to be able to support you as
well as possible and folks who are not
in a position to donate and so that
everyone has access to things that can
bridge them through this time
so keep putting your questions in on
YouTube and Facebook and I'd like to
introduce our guest Adam Green who runs
who's the head of our us content on Khan
Academy Adam good to see you good to see
you thanks al we're also joined here by
pistachio I know some of the folks in
the office
pistachio usually comes into the office
with me and I know that they're missing
her so I wanted to say hello from her
and also there's a neighborhood cat that
she usually likes to bark at about this
time of day so this is the best way to
make sure that she's not going to be
barking during this conversation but I
great to see you think so yes I am I
have mixed feelings towards pathetic
pistachio what one of the cutest dogs I
know but I I think they know that and
and so doesn't always give me the
attention that I think I deserve treats
treats are the the way to go
treat yeah anyway the Adam may be a good
place to start for everyone listening is
what what do you do here at Khan Academy
and what does the content P do here it
kind of got me sure thanks yeah so I
lead the content team the US academic
content team which basically means I
work with about 15 people that are all
really amazing content experts and
everything from math to science to
humanities social studies English
language arts and we all work together
to build all the great content that you
see on on Khan Academy for those core
courses and we're constantly working
that more you know I think go ahead
South yeah well I can go out adding more
one question I always get is well how
does kind of guide me determine what
content to add and then how does it go
about adding that content like what's
the day in the life of a Content team
member here at Khan Academy sure I think
that's one of the things if you were to
ask a content creator that's one of the
things that they really like about the
job is that there's all sorts of
different things that can be happening
depending on where you are in the
lifecycle of a course so we do a lot of
research to figure out what really just
do learners and teachers need out there
so everything from surveying teachers to
looking at lesson plans that are out
there to looking at state and national
standards to see really what can we
provide on our platform that
be of highest use to to learners and
teachers out there so we do that
research phase and then there's a whole
series of different phases for content
buildings depending on what type of
content we're actually working on if
it's videos articles exercises all of
those go through a pretty stringent
review process both internally and
externally as we create those resources
so we'll be building them as a team the
math team will get together and decide
hey we need to do more geometry we have
to add geometry exercises in the next
couple months that's what we've
determined will be the most use to
teachers and learners out there so
they'll start to build that they'll
build a plan then they'll be building
those exercises reviewing them
internally and then sending them for
external review to trusted teachers and
and other folks out there other content
experts and then we'll publish them on
the site and then we're not done there
we get a lot of feedback from folks like
the folks that are watching this YouTube
livestream right now we looked at every
single one of those pieces of feedback
that we get from from folks out there
and then we'll take that into
consideration when we work to improve
the content that we've put out and what
did the cue right now what can users out
there expect to see either improvements
or new courses or the next couple of
months yeah great question so where were
some of those we're pushing out more
quickly than we originally anticipated
we had a whole bunch of stuff planned
for the summer and some of those things
were releasing earlier because of this
crisis that we're in right now so you
might have seen we have new AP biology
and AP chemistry content that's out
there to help students with AP courses
we have all sorts of English language
arts content that's been coming out and
will continue to come out over the next
couple of months and we have big
refreshes on the math side in geometry
and in algebra and those are those are
sort of the big projects that are
happening right now and in the pipeline
we have all sorts of other other
projects for improvements in physics AP
Physics 1 and also we're looking to
build a civics course that hopefully the
first part of that civics course should
be out this summer and then we have a
whole new world history project that
we've developed in partnership with the
Gates Foundation and that's actually
hopefully going to be coming live
tomorrow on the site which is very
exciting
it's very all of this is very exciting
stuff so we're getting a lot of
questions about AP exams I do want to
let everyone know that the president and
CEO of the College Board the folks who
make the AP and the SAT he's going to be
on this livestream tomorrow David
Coleman but Adam what what how should
someone who is thinking about the AP
exams I guess we're about all really
we're weeks away from it now how would
you recommend students typically prepare
for it using Khan Academy and I know
there's a lot of you know consternation
maybe about how things might be
different this year how what advice are
you giving the students especially
relative to how they could use our
resources yeah there's a lot of packed
in there so I'll start off by talking
about how I would recommend using our
resources and I think that you have some
you've had some good advice in the past
two on that and we have a whole support
page that we've dedicated to the AP
being different this year and how you
can use Khan Academy resources to help
you but I think that really the first
thing that I would suggest is to make an
account it's free to do that
you can use our resources without making
an account but by having that free
account you can track your progress and
really use all of the tools available on
Khan Academy that will help show you
what you need to practice a little bit
more and what maybe you can practice a
little bit less to get prepared for the
for the exam so once you make that
account I think that there's really one
of two paths that I would recommend if
you're the kind of student where you
know that there's a unit or some topic
in the AP subject course that you're
about to take the exam for if you know
that there's a particular unit that you
need to brush up on then I would just go
right to that unit on Khan Academy let's
say you're an AP statistics students and
you know probability has been kind of
getting you down then you can go right
to the AP statistics course and jump
into that unit and start practicing and
watch some videos and articles I've read
some articles and then do some practice
to get and boned up on brushed up on
those sorts of that sort of topic and
and really feel more comfortable with
that particular unit if you're not sure
where you should start or you're already
feeling pretty good then my suggestion
would be to jump right to the course
challenge most of the AP courses that
Khan Academy offers have practice
content most of those courses are also
have mastery enabled features and one of
those mastery enabled features is the
course challenge so
you scroll all the way down to the
bottom of any particular AP course
you'll see course challenge you can
click that button it's like a 30 to 45
minute investment in time it's 30
questions and that really gives you a
big survey of all of the different types
of questions that you're likely to see
in the entire course once you get
through that you'll get a bit of a
report that shows you sort of how you're
doing on those and it can tell you which
topics that we think that you should
focus on a little bit more keep in mind
that the AP format is a bit different
this year and one of the pieces that's
different is the amount of content
that's going to be covered on that exam
in most cases it's about 75 percent of
the course or what most course most
classrooms will have covered by early
March of this year and these course
challenges they cover everything so you
in my opinion you should try to get
through all of the content for that
course because that'll really prepare
you for for the best experiencing in
college if you end up applying this
credit to college credits but the AP
exam this year itself will only cover
the first about 75% of the class and you
can get more information about what that
means which units are covered and not
covered both in that AP support post
that that we have on Khan Academy and
also through the College Board website
where you can get really specific
details about which units will be
covered on the exam and which ones won't
be covered on the exam so those are sort
of the two ways that that I would
approach it targeted practice if you
know you need targeted practice and if
you're not quite sure you're feeling
pretty good then jump into that course
challenge and and let our tools tell you
what you might want to focus on more but
you may have other suggestions too solid
love to hear from you oh well my
everything you just said I think what
you know in previous years the standard
ap format is you have you know roughly
half multiple choices and you have a
free response objection and I think the
Khan Academy you know our modality we
have multiple choice we also have things
like free respond of numeric entry not
you know long form pre response but that
really prepares you historically well
for the multiple-choice section of the
AP and I think to a reasonable degree
for the pre response but what I've
always told students is get to as much
mastery as you can Khan Academy just is
like this you mentioned and
and a few days or weeks before the exam
go through the worked examples of the
free response questions on Khan Academy
these are in video format and you know
when I or some other content creator
gives the question pause it try to solve
it on your by yourself before we solve
it and that'll really help you for the
free response I think that same
combination it's going to be really
effective for this year where it's going
to be a shorter pretty response focus
virtually proctored exam but I think
either way is that a mentioned that's
what's going to make you feel very
comfortable and confident in this year's
began so we even before you go on sale
just to double down on that not only do
we have those free response videos that
students can use in that sort of active
way to really pause the video try on
their own and then and then watch your
response to that in the AP resources
blog post that we have on Khan Academy
we have links to free response questions
from previous exams I think for most
exams at the last three years those go
right to college board and have PDFs of
the free response questions you can
practice with along with responses and
scoring guides for each of those so
although that most of our questions in
the AP courses on Khan Academy are
multiple-choice or something close to it
they're all designed really with free
being able to answer free response
questions in mind they take you through
the thought process and the sort of
modeling that thought that you would
need in order to be successful in the
free response questions so even though
you may be practicing and using the
mastery system using something
multiple-choice or close to it
you're really laying that foundation to
have a firm understanding of all the
content that you need in order to be
successful in those free response
questions so yeah I would do mastery
stuff first then I would watch the Sal
videos that go through the free response
questions from the past few years and
then finally at the end I would look at
those College Board resources for free
response questions and try to work
through those on your own and look at
those scoring guides and sample
responses and follow in that progression
over the next you know four to six weeks
or potentially a little bit longer
depending on when your exam actually is
you should be in pretty good shape
there's a lot of resources out there for
everybody plus there's College Board
resources like you
to videos that they're doing live
YouTube review sessions for all of the
different courses and you can get
information for that both on our AP blog
post and also on the College Board
website it's super super useful and
let's see we have some questions this is
from YouTube Pamela Criswell asks what
is your suggestion for the best ways for
teachers to use Khan Academy since we
have had to go to remote learning I
could take a first stab at that Pamela
and I'd love to hear what you have to
say as well Adam so I think there's
several ways that you could use Khan
Academy before the school closures when
school is in session what we've seen is
if teachers are able to have their
students work on personalized learning
mastery learning on Khan Academy even
forty-five minutes a week the back has
been associated with accelerated
outcomes on a wide variety of measures
and that is something like let's say
you're a sixth grade teacher you can
assign the sixth grade course mastery to
your students and that's something that
could take all year so it could take a
good amount of time and so the kids over
the year are going to learn their own
time and pace try to get things leveled
up and you as a teacher are going to get
a dashboard where you can see who's
progressing who's not who's engaged
who's not who's getting stuck on certain
concepts and then in class time you can
take some of the kids who are stuck and
you could do a focused intervention with
them you can maybe pair them up or you
could pair them with a student who might
have already mastered that concept we've
seen that real work really well now that
we have this school closure situation
what we're seeing a lot of teachers do
is lean on that a little bit more where
they can now expect a set of 45 minutes
a week depending on the age group
anywhere between 20 to 60 minutes a day
of being able to work on their math at
their own time and pace one of the
things we did a few weeks ago is we
released these daily schedules for
students of different age groups that
articulated hey for this age group maybe
45 minutes of Khan Academy math at this
time of the day might make sense well
we're going to be releasing over the
next couple of days are actually
learning plan we're not just over
through the end of the school year but
also potentially leveraging the summer
so students can make sure that they have
a plan to cover all of the major
concepts
that they need to to be at grade level
or or above for students who maybe are
weak in some of their foundations we
recommend let's save their sixth grade
students again keep going on 5th grade
but simultaneously also try to get
mastery on arithmetic on Khan Academy to
make sure they have really really really
strong foundations now as a teacher one
of the things I think we've seen
teachers do really well is if there's a
certain time of day kids are working on
Khan Academy at their own time and pace
you can monitor that but also if you
could make yourself available via Google
hangout or zoom or something like that
where students can jump on maybe a
couple of times a week ask you questions
you can work through worked examples
with them admit real it should feel like
a tutorial because everyone's looking
for that social connection right now so
the more interactive it is the better so
I think something like that that type of
flow is really powerful and also
encouraging parents and students to
continue through the summer you know
we're in a tough scenario right over
here where it looks like most of the
country schools are going to be closed
probably through the end of the school
year and so there's a loss there of two
months but then there's an opportunity
to maybe leverage the summer as well to
make sure students are at grade level
Adam anything to add to that no I think
you cover that really really well
all right you know if we think of war
and all of you teachers out there a lot
of what we are trying to recommend the
teachers it's coming from teachers doing
a great job so we're all learning this
this together so so send us your ideas
as well and so there is so a quick
question so Jamil b.p Liana gay says do
we have content for TOEFL unfortunately
do not have TOEFL content and that's the
test for foreign students who need to
show English proficiency we we don't
have that yet or or we don't have plans
for that let's see we have a question
from YouTube Suzanna Garcia Dominguez
says how can I use your science course
to prove that I have mastered middle
school science but I have a few ideas
buzz but Adam I'd love your take on that
yeah that's a we don't have specific
content out for middle school classrooms
yet that's something that we're hoping
to work on in the future but right now I
would take a look
things like high school biology we do
have courses in chemistry and in physics
and if you can work your way through
those courses and we have all those
resources on Khan Academy that if you're
a really motivated student which it
sounds like you really are then you can
watch those videos read articles and you
can continue to practice those exercises
over and over and see new types of
questions and that's going to be a
really great way for you to start to
build that mastery in those in those
courses in terms of being able to show
that you've done that I think they're
just having that knowledge in your head
and being able to talk with that with
your teachers and fellow students is is
the best way that we can help support
that right now but Sal what do you think
yeah I would just add to that what I've
been telling a lot of students is that
you know some of these courses that are
labeled high school courses you could
try engaging in this is a great time to
try it out I think high school biology
is something that a lot of middle school
students can engage in you know the math
you need you already have and you know
you start learning the basics what is
life what dna/rna an obvious evil virus
very very relevant things right now I
think we're all a little bit more
motivated than normal to learn about
viruses and RNA and DNA and and things
like that and also on the math side
exponential growth
so I recommend high school biology is a
great place to go and if as a middle
school student you're able to engage in
it's going to be a great leg up not just
for high school in college so it's going
to be a great you'll sound smart at
dinner parties these days if you talk
about how RNA is more likely the mutate
and you'll be able to keep up with some
of the biologists out there so that's
that that's what I would recommend I'm
actually even doing it with some of my
kids because everyone's curious right
now about this and I think you're ready
to learn it especially if you have that
motivation to do so so let's see we have
from Facebook Jane molnár says any plans
for upper division math classes or like
abstract algebra or complex analysis so
I hear you you know as a math nerd I'm
just talking to myself in the affect
most affectionate possible way I would
love to do that at some point our focus
has been trying to do the courses that
the most students have the most trouble
with right now
but I hope one day we do get into some
of the more advanced we do have things
like multivariable differential
equations linear algebra but you're
really talking about a complex analysis
really isn't around that level as well
so I hope we are able to get there over
the next many years but it's it's not
part of our pipeline and just yet okay
so I have a Facebook atom move carry to
Sal an atom how will Khan Academy get me
into Stanford Adam I don't think that's
our job not directly our job what I will
say putting my guidance counselor had on
is first I wouldn't over index on any
one school it's really more what you
make of it but my advice generally and
it's great to have today I miss school
or that school is where I could imagine
myself is just be curious learn as much
as you can do it for authentic reasons
do other interesting things above and
beyond your academics but don't do it
just to be able to fill out a college
application the college admissions folks
that I know are good at spotting you
know engineered applications they like
authenticity and you know just to get to
know who you are as a person and how you
might be able to contribute to the world
and then when you apply to colleges just
be your authentic self
don't try to be some version of what you
think that admissions officer wants to
see and if for whatever reason your true
authentic self isn't what gets you in to
some school well that's probably good
it's like a marriage if your true
authentic self and the other person
doesn't want to marry you well it's good
to know before you get married then
after the fact so my advice is just be
curious learn use this time right now to
work on interesting things ways to help
your community inventions or whatever
else you know I've been thinking about
wouldn't it be cool if there gloves but
not only protect you from the virus but
kill the virus on anything it touches
you know I've been walking into the
supermarket with like Clorox wipes on
both hands and I go like the mills open
it up I'm like model
am i protecting myself but I'm
protecting the next person to open this
door so I think there's plenty of
opportunity for invention Adam any any
advice do you have for for Adam a great
name yeah I think that the that what
you're saying
rings rings really true college
admissions counselors and and all those
folks have seen it all before they're
gonna know if you're just writing for
that you should really be writing for
yourself and be yourself and and yeah
just to just s L said be curious about
the world around you and and just just
be your authentic self both before
during and after the college admissions
process and things will generally work
out yeah and we have this question from
from instagrams
Sarah underscore mode 66 says what if
students do not have reliable access to
the Internet
my advice is you know videos are a
little bit harder with intermittent
access to the internet our exercise
platform does leverage the Internet to
be able to keep track of what you're
doing or not but it's not that intensive
from the data point of view so you
should be able to work on the exercises
get the feedback and our Khan Academy's
iPhone or tablet and phone app actually
does allow you to download and sync so
you can do that kind of thing overnight
and then you can have a little bit more
consistent of an experience but this is
a major problem there's obviously a lot
of kids that's in the United States
going around the world who don't have
access to Internet and we're going to
you know what we're not the folks who
can distribute laptops or distribute
Internet but we are trying to work with
telecom carriers and other folks to to
see how we can help solve that that
issue let's see other questions that we
are seeing we are seeing so YouTube's
able not to not me says what can I do on
Khan Academy during this time I'm Adam
you want to take a first stab at that
there's a lot you could do it's so many
things there are literally hundreds of
courses on Khan Academy that you can
play around with so I would suggest
mixing things up a little bit if you
if you're in viola biology course or if
you're you know in fifth grade taking
math do a little bit of work in those
those courses but also just sort of look
around poke around and follow your nose
follow your whatever you happen to be
interested in we have content on there
from Pixar Pixar in a box if you're
interested in animation we have lots of
computing courses on there so if you're
interested in computer science or
learning something about programming you
can poke around in there there's just a
lot going on in the Khan Academy
universe and I would just suggest kind
of opening things up and looking at
something that maybe you haven't looked
at before something that you've heard
might be interesting and just just play
around it's an open sandbox and I think
that yo you'll find some you'll find a
lot of things in there that that will be
interesting to you especially in this
time where you might have a little bit
more time or a little bit more
flexibility to get interested in things
and I'll just add to what Adam said Abel
a bell or Abel yes you know you this bad
situation the world finds itself in it
there's a silver lining that you now
have time and if you construct your day
you have every day you can spend you
know sessions I don't know how older you
are but you could spend sessions with
twenty minutes at a time 30 minutes at a
time maybe three or four of those
sessions you could make sure you have
super solid foundations in math by doing
everything that we've been talking about
not just in this live stream but in
previous ones where you can get practice
feedback take that course challenge if
you're feeling a little bit of weakened
in these subjects you can remediate with
things like our arithmetic or so our
pre-algebra course and if you're feeling
good just keep going between now and the
start of school I can't tell you enough
how confident that will make you in
whatever subject you you engage in so
that can be in math I encourage folks
who feel they're ready even at the
middle school level especially the high
school level get a leg up on biology
chemistry and physics because you have
the time now but then a year or two from
now when you're taking those courses and
you're taking six or seven courses and
you have homework you're like oh I wish
I used those five months a little bit
better I would also encourage you read a
lot right now and and think critically
about that reading I would even if
you're not planning on taking the SAT in
the next several month I actually
the SAT practice on Khan Academy that
we've been doing with the College Board
it's not just in math it's in reading
and writing as well there's just a great
practice in general to sharpen those
skills and get you ready for problems
related to this question from YouTube
sri harsha pirate Shuhei says do you
guys have plans to do a guide for the
GRE as y'all have done for the SAT and
and and sri harsha is very generous you
guys really really help me out on this
and i can't thank you guys enough well
thank you Shree Harsha unfortunately
don't have GRE prep right now but you
know I think that SAT prep is fairly
general purpose a lot of folks have also
asked about the a CT Allison gabble on
Facebook asked about it we don't have a
CT specific prep either but once again
if you get really good these things are
all highly highly correlated SAT grea T
G if you use our SAT work and get really
strong at it that's going to transfer I
believe to to two other tests so it
looks like we're all at time it's always
fun I want to thank Adam for joining us
he does a you know a lot of folks think
that Khan Academy is still Stalin so
walk-in closet although I am back enough
I'm in my and our kids kind of a
workroom right now but it's a it's a
team effort and what you see is a
finished product of over 200 folks out
of Leeds a large chunk of that and you
know pokes hopefully appreciate that
there's a lot of folks who are
dedicating their their time and energy
to this effort and I want to thank all
of them and you know before we head out
I just want to remind everyone you know
stay safe stay healthy stay socially
distant that's the best way that we can
stop the spread of what we're all going
through and I want to thank you for
joining because not only is this a way
for all of you to feel connected it's a
way for us to feel connected to you
which we all need right now and I'll
just say again a reminder Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit we are dependent on
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself every dollar matters so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to Khan Academy you
can see the links at the end it's kind
of ketamine org slash donate thank you
so much have a have a great Monday